Israeli government just trying to keep
the Palestinian minority out of the
system
nevermind represents you Arab or Jew
Palestinian or Israeli departed that the
present your right to be above the line
of poverty just to feel human actually
in Israel
it's the only part that say that we
should end the occupation and give all
the money that people that the
government puts in the if occupation on
the sill emancipated in God and
education if in the health system
I'm voting for the joint list because I
believe that we can make proper change
it's good for Israel to have a strong
party the best outcome for sure it's
with the other full city and living in
Israel's vault